per tanti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
non vi dico sono felice io oggi siamo su
un gioco che ha un nome incredibile si
chiama my friends pedro e devo
assolutamente farvi vedere la intro
ditemi voi sono nel gioco della vita se
si chiama così non poteva non essere
allora my friends pedro credo si tratti
di questa banana qua credo theory che
poi non lo so ho preso infatti un to
start va bene ma se c'è l'italiano ci
hanno messo il coreano hanno messo
persino il picco ma niente italiano
fantastico c'è la difficoltà c'è un po
di roba new game non sono anche come si
faccia perché non sono anche di cosa si
tratta però c'è una banana quindi non
possiamo non giocarlo ei zap come stai
wake up va bene mi sono svegliato sono
una banana voleva sesta panara cos'è sta
roba
rising shines sleepy ed alzati e
splendido milione essendo io sono qua
sono io questo ma non sono una banana ma
pedro e rilassati smi peggio your
friends
ma guarda te vuol jumping a ok forse fa
rivolgiamo vabbè grazie pedro grazie mia
mamma mia videogioco incredibile puoi
fare wall jump vale tutti i centesimi
kroos peso cioè pistola ovviamente ma
dai
a mescolare il suo gioco va bene ci
siamo ho una pistola e posso fare voi
jumping ottimo e mitch il macellaio il
macellaio devo farlo fuori sei pronto ok
aiuto ho vinto io non è family friendly
che sfiga ho lasciato pistola adesso
cosa vuol dire quando pistole posso fare
fuori tutti adesso come posso fare tipo
james bond o mio dio
questi sono sempre due case è fatto
benissimo sto gioco aspettato fare sparo
mentre facevo il jumping
aiuto mi hanno fatto malissimo fa niente
sono io
salve mamma mia cosa ho fatto
si possono fare le figate cosa ma
bisogna che mi ha portato si sta facendo
mi è entrata la banana in testa a vista
spiegando le cose ma io posso fare
questa roba
ma io quindi posso modificare il tema ma
dai è tipo super 8
quindi adesso posso sparare a più
persone ok uno è locato el'altro lo
sparo spenti sparo
no noi morto ok a posto bellissimo e
belle ragazze e bellissimo che joe king
la maledizione allora questo è locato a
sparagli sparagli manager un è morto
l'altro rimasto giù come mamma mia
ragazzi è veramente geniale e geniale
c'è un gioco incredibile mamma via lata
player mi dà una soddisfazione
incredibile sta roba incredulità di
giuro cioè immagino che dopo diventerà
difficilissimo però mi dà una
soddisfazione assurda fare sta roba
cioè vi giuro ma anche four nights ci
sono anche le trappole ma non è il
puntino a deve schivare ok a puoi
schivare le robe ventre saltinaria
finissimo quindi puoi anche schivare la
roba bo aiuto lo scriva per schivare
basta che faccio le trottole gesto male
con quale logica bastano delle trottole
per schivare cioè io e tutto sto casino
devo far fuori il macellaio di prima
perché non l'ho mica capita sta roba
penso di sì e geniale perché non hai
capito la piccola il mio obiettivo però
ci sta panara che mi aiuta a fare le
cose
io vorrei avere una banana come amica
comunque ho sempre desiderato suo gioco
mi aiuta a fare questo a rendere
orgoglioso il me stesso guardali
guardali che provata no occhio non
l'avevo visto questo mai
[Musica]
mamma mia ma a posto mi sono schiantato
ma fa niente
l'elenco clip è stato belli mi sono dato
un sacco
non ho ancora ben capito dove stiamo
andando in tutto questo comunque pedro
sei veramente l'amico più fidato del
mondo
non potevo desiderare un amico migliore
di te meno male che ti ho trovato
ragazzi chiunque dovrebbe avere una
banana per amico io lo dico anche rim ha
protestato ma questa gente cosa sta
facendo nei cunicoli si può uccidere
basta perfetto perfetto
ora mi sono anche atterrati in testa di
posso calciare i nemici funzione eco
studiare calcio i nemici vabbè occhio
sono quasi morto qua perfetto dovevo
stare attento a non farmi ammazzare per
con un deficiente no perché io sono
capace passa robert nora guiu te lo devo
fare un casino d'oggi film ho fatto un
disastro per farli fuori mesi però ci
sono riuscito flip a posso flippare il
tavolo per scoprirlo adesso è ottimo
quasto rischiando e ragga fatto
rischiano rischiando tra di schianto
sono vivo direi un calcione marones
eccolo era proprio quello che volevo
ciao fratello se li è il titolo mamma
mia quanto family friends in soggiorno
ragazzi proprio quello che volevo
dopo tanto tempo level complete
quant'altro di forma ma vabbè ci sono
tre armi ma c'è anche lusi
è meglio che mi usi saranno anche loro
ecco perché la propria intanto aveva
capito tramite il loro tiro dai sola
menaio dai anche agli altri ma scusami o
doppio usi adesso mio figlio sono vivo
per cosa per niente
nora gafà muoio muoio subito perché ci
sono due vie calcio di l'art
ce l'ho fatta non so con che criterio ma
ce lo fa e va beh ragazzi sta diventando
un casino io lo dico detto rai o madonna
quanto ci sono messo qua aiuto che
parole non lo uccise muoio muoio noi
invece sono mica scherza
e allora se devo morire così morirò così
felice cosa sto scrivendo
non è vero sono vivo ragazzi cosa vi
supplico replay 9 va no vabbè qua
incredible fatto una roba che non saprei
di fare mai ma neanche per sbaglio
adesso hanno messo pure gli slide suo
nome ragazze vivremo un punto in questo
gioco sarà difficilissimo c'è proprio
che non riuscivo a far le robe quindi e
rai joe di brutto perché sta diventando
sta diventando già difficile adesso
figuriamoci dopo cerchia vaticano dove
diventa un disastro mondiale
vabbè vabbè vabbè vedo cose strane nella
mia vita mio dio aspetta al bagno rimane
volo perfetto perfetto non ce l'ho fatta
non è vero mamma mia ragazzi ma che
gioco incredibile ma chi se l'è
inventata sta roba è per niente così
rampini e incredibile mi rampi fanno
rendono la faccenda veramente [ __ ] molto
più del normale
scommetto un biscotto che non riuscirai
a calciare la palla dentro il canestro a
calciando una propria foto calciare sono
scarsino cristiano ronaldo bellissimo e
mi dispiace perché ho mangiato tutti i
biscotti va bene questo serve perché
sicuramente adesso ci sarà una roba dove
poi calciare gli oggetti fatti dai
cancelli e ti faccia lione ora a buttare
giù quel tipo con la palla va bene ma
come come fa morire la gente con la
palla se quella roba lì puoi far
esplodere tutto ciò io ci credo
mi sa che lo deve inseguire con la moto
c'è ti pare veramente lo inseguirlo con
la moto ci vorrà una moto ma veramente
ma che gioco ai ragazzi a giocare
e allora
ci pare la gente dai vai che la sta
diventando che casino aiuto
[Musica]
ma stiamo scherzando che sta succedendo
geniale potete essere in così tanti oca
vacca se va bene che sta diventando un
trash incredibile madonna ragazzo sabato
c'è su quei salta poi fare i front lip
con la moto con la moto cioè io non ho
parole
fa meglio non possono che tutti i vari
proiettili veramente nocent oggi
non so neanche come mi sto muovendo
proprio missile buccia l'ho trovato
finalmente il box ci ho messo una vita
ma l'ho trovato che doveri e imbecille
ha parlato italiano no c'è anche gli
scagnozzi
devo capire arma previste così è
successo lì pagherai per quello che hai
fatto bio ristorante guarda che possa
ancora ribaltare il risultato e allora
fuori o è stato molto difficile ragazzi
ragazzi s ho preso al finale ho preso il
massimo che gioco raga incredibile sono
contento va bene signori questo era my
friends pedro così pedro superiore video
vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale
fatemi sapere se volete il continuo
schiacciate la campanella per ricevere
le notifiche a tutti i video con carico
se non mi arrivavano tipica e noi come
sempre ci rivediamo ambrosio ride beh
ragazzi
[Musica]